الامريكية والغربية الواصلة
للاوكران? نعم. انها المافيا يا
حتى انه قد يسعى للحصول على مقعد
في البرلمان الروسي بحسب صحيفة
ها هو فيكتور باك لا يكتفي
بادارة الحرب لينضم الى السياسة
الامريكية ولم يقبل بترغيبهم ولا
بتهديدهم. رغم سجنه لاكثر من عقد
نفسها في موقف محرج جدا. نعم.
لقد الحت روسيا كثيرا على
تنظيم القاعدة اسامة بن لادن.
لكن هذا العدو في الوقت ذاته هو
وقعت واشنطن في المحظور لتكتشف
عام الفين واربعة من خلال
الغرب ملك الحرب او تاجر الموت.
وبعد عودته عادت الحياة للقوات
معلومات سربت الصحافة البريطانية
انها كانت تتعامل مع فيكتور بوت
خامسا قد يطعنها في الظهر في اي
وقت. وفق تقرير نشرته صحيفة
الاوكراني. بعد ان كانت شرارة
الحرب الروسية قد انطلقت في
او باخرى كانت امريكا سوقا مربحا
فيا له من ثعلب ماكر. وبعد ان
الروسية في الاراضي الاوكرانية.
وعاد السلاح للتدفق لتنطلق
فيكتور بوت. من حكمت عليه
الولايات المتحدة بالسجن خمسة
طائرته متروكة على المدارج بين
موسكو وكييف. هائلة من الاسلحة.
داخل اربعة جدوران. لكن علاقاته
وادارته للحروب لم تتوقف. وبعد
التي قدم بعضها من منطقة
القوقازي بعد طردها من جورجيا
لتسارع اجهزة الامن الاوكرانية
لتتعامل مع شبكات المافيا القوية
يحملان مصير اوديسا في راحتيهما.
فعن اي سيطرة نتحدث. تاجر الموت.
وهما رجلا اعمال يعيشان بين لندن
واوكرانيا. وتقول لوموند انهما
وفلاديمير جالاناتي الملقبين
بالملاك والكاردينال الاسود.
واستقرارها في مدينة اوديسا.
اجهزة الامن الاوكرانية في
كوسانوسترا بصقلية على تخزين
اسلحة حربية ومتفجرات كانت معدة
اشهر المافيات الروسية الشيشاني
الاصل حوز الذي يعني اسمه
يشبه هؤلاء من حيث نظامهم
الداخلي المافيا الايطالية ومن
فهناك عصابات متوحشة قوقازية
الاصل كالشيشان والجورجيين. حيث
المافيا المشتبه في موالاتها
لموسكو والتي ترى فيها طابورا
لوموند الفرنسية. لكن كان الفأس
قد وقع على الرأس ايها الاوكرار.
الاوكرانية الواحدة بعد الاخرى
بيد قوات الروس كييف الى تحييد
انهيار الاتحاد السوفيتي ازداد
نفوذها. المافيا تخترق الداخل
السلاح التي كانت في احد الاحياء
الشعبية في كاتانيا. لنعد الى
والكثير ممن تسمى عصابات المافيا
هناك. هي ليست روسية الاصل.
للبيع خارج ايطاليا. ان السلطات
الايطالية تمكنت من مداهمة مخازن
اوكرانيا ومافيا موسكو قد انجزت
مهمتها. تساقطت الاراضي
قلق متزايد من قبل مسئولي الامن
داخل روما. حيث اقدمت مافيا
بالعربي الطير. المافيا الروسية
مشهورة بقوة انشطتها. فبعد
مافيا بوتن. وفي الحقيقة فلا
يوجد وصف دقيق للمافيا الروسية.
شخصيات عديدة منها رجال اعمال
وسياسيون مثل الكسندر انجويرت
بحسب التقارير الامريكية والتي
تتحدث عن سوق سوداء للاسلحة في
الحرب السياسية ضد الغرب من جهة
اخرى. الولايات المتحدة
الجارديان. ليدير المافيا على
الارض الاوكرانية ويشارك في
وقوة مافيا الروس على الاراضي
الاوكرانية. ولسان حال المافيا
وسواء تم بيع الاسلحة ام تم
استخدامها. فكل الطرق تؤدي لنمو
يستخدمونها عوضا عن البيع. فهل
علمتم? من الذي يبيع الاسلحة
اصدقاء. لكن من يشتري هذه
الاسلحة قد يكون هو تاجر الحرب.
لاوكرانيا لا تصل جميعها. وان
وصلت فلا تستخدم جميعها في الحرب
استعادة تأجير الحروب بوت.
والسبب صلاته وعلاقاته بدوائر
بانضمامه الى الحزب الليبرالي
الديموقراطي الموالي للكرملين.
قليلة من الافراج عنه في صفقة
تبادل اسرى بين روسيا وامريكا.
اوكرانيا لكن ليست جميع الاسلحة
تباع. فمن يأخذونها? قد
في زنزانة انفرادية تبعد الاف
الكيلومترات عن بلده. بعد ايام
الامريكية في حالة ليان واضطراب.
فسيل الاسلحة التي تقدمها
الذي اغتنم الفرصة بعد انهيار
الاتحاد. انه رجل المافيا الاول
القرار والمخابرات العسكرية
الروسية. لكن قيمته الحقيقية
الشريك السري الذي تتعامل معه
الدولة. لتضع الولايات الامريكية
الكارثي هناك عام الفين وثلاثة.
كانت الفضيحة ضخمة. ليصبح فيكتور
وعشرين عاما عام الفين واحد عشر.
امضى منها اكثر من احد عشر عاما
دولار. وذلك حين كان الامريكان
يعيدون بناء العراق بعد خطأهم
وضعت اسم تاجر الموت فيكتور بو
على قائمتها السوداء لكن بطريقة
الجيوش بعد تراجع طويل. فضيحة
مدوية. كانت الولايات المتحدة قد
واشنطن ليعود لعمله المفضل.
تجارة البشر والشر ليطلق عليه
عدة من حرب روسيا ضد اوكرانيا
استطاعت موسكو اخراجه من سجون
جنوده من استغنت عنهم الدولة
فدفع لهم اكثر. الضابط السوفيتي
مقاولين وسطاء في اطار صفقة
موقعة معه قيمتها ستين مليون
الذي تلاحقه اجهزتها السرية.
كالذي يضيء بنور جواله ليبحث عنه
حوله. يا لغباء كوب. كان بوت
يتاجر معهم بشكل مباشر او من
باط هو العدو الاول الذي تطارده
الولايات المتحدة. بعد زعيم
بالنسبة للروس هو رفضه الدائم
الى التعاون مع السلطات
تفكيك دول الاعداء واحالة المدن
الى خراب. نبدأهم ان الحروب تبدأ
القوية. جيش غير جيشه المعروف.
يضربون تحت الحزام. مهماتهم
سوداء. عالم مرعب وظلام. ها هو
بوتين يظهر يده الاخرى الخفية
يقتصر عملهم على شغل العصابات.
فالمافيا الروسية هي اليد
الحرب ومن ينهيها. انهم المافيا
يا سادة. تجار الدم والنار. لم
يعد عملهم هو الاتجار بالمخدرات
او المتاجرة باعضاء البشر. ولم
نتحدث. وللقصة بقية. المافيا
تلملم اوراقها لتشتت اوكرانيا.
دولة قوية وراء ظهورهم. عن
المافيا الروسية في اوكرانيا
الوقت الذي يعجز فيه الجواسيس
ويقوى فيه الاعداء. من يبدأ
الضاربة لبوتين في اوكرانيا. حيث
بدأ عملها قبل الحرب ولن تنتهي
مهمتهم بنهايتها. وبكل الاحوال
فاموالهم تزيد ولا تنقص وتقف
داخل جيش العدو. نعم. فهناك تكون
مهمتهم الرئيسية. يظهرون في
اخر قد بدأ عمله في الداخل. حيث
بدأت المافيا الروسية بحربها
عندما كان الجنود الروس يحتشدون
في حدود اوكرانيا. كان هناك جيش
دول الجوار الاوكراني لترتبك
معها العديد من الدول الاوروبية
لانتشار الجرائم وكان عنصر جذب
لعصابات دولية من بينها المافيا
ان اندلعت الحرب حتى بدأت
المافيا بنشر الفوضى في اوكرانيا
في اوكرانيا من تعلم موعد اندلاع
الحرب. لك اخفت نفسها جيدا. وما
في واحدة من مهامهم الرئيسية
لترويع الاوكراني وتسهيل امور
باقتصاداتها. هناك تهيأت البيئة
الخصبة للمافيا هذا هو ملعبها.
الايطالية. خرجت وكالة انسا
الايطالية وقالت ان المافيا بدأت
مبكرا التحرك لاستغلال الحرب
الاوكرانية لتحقيق مكاسب. وسط
قوات موسكو القادمة بقوة. ها هو
شهر يمضي على الحرب والفوضى قد
انتشرت فعلا في الداخل. ازداد
الارتباك على الحدود الذي شهدته
ممهدة للقوات الروسية التي
ستأتي. وكانت المافيا هي الوحيدة
يقول للامريكان هل من مزيد يا
اصدقاء?